okay winner is in with less than 1% of
votes the New York Times has called
Donald Donald Trump the winner of the
IUS I I was told I was told by team
DeSantis that Dan santis was going to
win that didn't happen wow wow less than
1% votes in no way are there other 7:32
I don't understand still very is my mic
even on yeah I think you're a little
quiet and so was yeah well that's good
for both of them actually perfect maybe
they're in that screaming M oh Ryan got
two
votes please I just want V to beat Nikki
he's he's within 12 votes of beating
Nikki Haley that's incredible that's a
good sign come on you got this I got to
be honest I I just
hope fails the race has been called by
the Associated Press the race was called
before most of the votes were reported
which often means the call was based on
polls and other data oh okay so so we
can go home now is done I no I think
it's I I I think we're all happy to hear
that uh Donald Trump want